MALE SPEAKER: Welcome everybody
to one more Talks at Google
today.
Our guest is Jan Jarboe Russell.
She is a journalist.
Her newest book is "The
Train to Crystal City."
Jan Jarboe Russell is a Nieman
Fellow, a contributing editor
for the "Texas Monthly."
She has written for
the "San Antonio
Express News," "The New
York Times," "Slate,"
and other magazines.
Jan is the author also of
"Lady Bird, a Biography of Mrs.
Johnson" and has also
compiled and edited
"They Lived to Tell the Tale."
Jan lives in San Antonio, Texas,
with her husband, Dr. Louis F.
Russell, Jr.
In "The Train to
Crystal City," you'll
encounter the secret history
of an American internment camp
in Crystal City, Texas, where
men of German, Japanese,
and Italian descent and
their families, many of whom
were US citizens, were
ripped from their homes
across the United
States and Latin America
and deposited in Crystal
City without due process.
Please welcome Jan
Jarboe Russell to Google.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL:
Thank you so much.
I am from Texas.
And I do bring greetings
and gratitude to Google
for connecting us to our world.
You know, Texas can be a
kind of dry and arid place
in all ways, intellectually
as well as the land area.
And so I was asked by
a poet friend of mine
to tell you that Google
is like the sap of a very
nice tree, lots and
lots of things going on.
In 2010, when I started
work on this book,
I just never thought that the
book would be so of the moment.
But ironically, the
presidential rhetoric
that we're hearing
today is remarkably
similar to the kind
of debates that we
were hearing after the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor in 1941.
Then, it was the
Japanese, the immigrants
from what they call Axis
Nations-- Japan, Germany,
and Italy.
And those were the ones
that were targeted.
But now, of course, it's
Latinos and Muslims.
The Enemy Alien Act of
1798 gives the president,
then and now, the
power to simply take
a person who is a legal
or an illegal immigrant
from a country that
we are at war with.
So this rule, this law,
is still in effect.
And it means that the next
president could indeed
set up internment camps
if he wanted to, certainly
could build a wall.
And so while this history may
seem remote to some of you,
it is, in fact,
absolutely current
in terms of legal
and other matters.
As many of you know, after
the attack on Pearl Harbor,
Roosevelt shifted
his whole emphasis
from The New Deal, which
was the policies that were
at home, to the war effort.
And he was much more aggressive
and angry at the Germans
and the Italians
and the Japanese
than we have yet to know.
Most everyone knows, of course,
about the 120,000 Japanese
and Japanese-Americans that
were taken during the war.
But we now know that there were
a lot more Germans and Italians
as well taken, and that there
were more in internment camps
than we knew.
I personally have found
80 different camps.
And so in this picture,
this was the photograph
of the Roosevelts' December
1942 Christmas card.
And in this picture, Eleanor
has fought against internment
of citizens and had in
fact, come to San Francisco
and told the Japanese,
don't worry about a thing.
And Roosevelt, he
thought that Germany
would get us into the war.
In fact, he said, Germany first.
And so he told his
attorney general,
I don't really care that
much about the Italians.
But I'm really worried
about these Germans.
But the Italians, they're
just a bunch of opera singers.
So he was very, very
angry at the Germans
and wanted to intern a
whole lot of them, something
that we didn't know.
This is the history
of the camp that you
do know, the evacuation of
the people from the West Coast
that were Japanese-Americans.
If you had 1/16 of an ounce of
Japanese blood in your veins,
you were considered
Japanese and taken
to what were called the
10 relocation camps.
This is a very
important photograph
by the great photographer,
Dorothea Lange, who documented
the evacuation of the Japanese.
And it's about one
of the characters
in my book from San
Francisco, the Fukuda family.
This is Mrs. Fukuda.
This is her daughter Makiko
and some of her other children.
The reasons I like
this is that it
brings to mind the details of
the photograph, the humanity
of these people.
She was pregnant.
And so that's why she
looks a little large.
But see how carefully
that they are dressed.
The Japanese could only
take what they could carry.
They lost everything else.
And so you see what
she is carrying here.
This man in the photograph
is now 80 years old
and lives in San Francisco,
having survived the war.
And by the same token, you
see the army people here
that are also well-dressed
and putting them on the bus.
She went to Santa
Anita Race Track,
where she gave birth to her
last son in a horse stable.
And you know, if that,
the smell of horse
manure, in that stable.
and that was her last pregnancy.
She was married to
Reverend Fukuda, who
has had the Konko Church
in San Francisco, which
still is in an existence
in San Francisco.
They took the ministers
of all three countries
first because they
were considered
leaders of their country.
So Fukuda who was arrested
because he was a preacher.
And none of the
enemy alien fathers
were charged with any crime.
They did not know how long
their internment would be.
And they had no way to
hire a lawyer or anything.
They were arrested not
because the government found
them personally to be
saboteurs, but because they
were citizens of the country
that we were suddenly
at war with.
I love this photograph of
Mrs. Fukuda and her son, Nob,
because you can see
her magnificent face
and her humanity as she
is being carted off.
My book, "The Camp in Crystal
City," served two purposes.
One of them could be
considered humane.
And that is that when enemy
alien fathers were arrested,
they lost everything.
They lost their businesses.
They lost their homes.
And if they were
Japanese, the families
could go to the
relocation camps.
If you were Italian or
German, you had nowhere to go.
You could either go to
county relief or whatever.
So the government said, we need
to get these families together.
And so they created the
only internment camp
of multiple nationalities
in Crystal City, Texas.
And while that seems to
be a humanitarian thing
to do, of course, there's no
such thing as a good internment
camp.
The second reason was
even more hard to believe
and more mind-boggling.
The camp in Crystal City served
as the center of Roosevelt's
prisoner exchange program.
Over the course
of the war, there
were six different
prisoner exchanges,
where we traded people
from Crystal City, which
became the center of
the exchanges, all
of the exchanges.
We traded German
fathers and mothers
and their American-born children
for ostensibly more important
Americans that were
trapped in Germany.
The same happened in Italy.
And he created this
camp in Crystal City.
The State Department created it.
It was called Quiet Passage.
And they put these
people in these camps.
And in order to be reunited
with their families,
they each had to sign a paper
saying that if the government
needed you to go back to
your country of origin
that you would.
And that was the price for being
reunited with their parents.
My book tells the
stories from the point
of view of two teenaged
girls and their families,
both of whom became barter
in the prisoner exchange.
They were American-born girls.
The first was Ingrid.
This is the Eiserloh family.
And they are from
Cleveland, Ohio.
This is Ingrid.
This is Ensila.
This is Lothar.
And this is Johanna.
Their father Matthias
had been arrested.
The FBI had three categories
for who could be arrested.
Category A was if you were
a member of the Nazi party,
you were arrested, or
the equivalent of that
in the Japanese and
Italian communities.
Category B was if you had an
occupation which our government
thought might be
useful to our enemies,
then you were arrested.
And that was how
Matthias became arrested.
He was an engineer, an
honorable occupation.
And he was an engineer
in Cleveland, Ohio.
And he had built a lot
of roads and bridges.
And the FBI, when I got
his FBI file declassified,
it said that if he could
build these roads and bridges
that he could blow them up.
And so he was arrested
and taken away.
And this particular
photograph of the family
is the last photograph
they had in their home
because four months after
Matthias was arrested,
they didn't have any more money.
In those days, Johanna
had had a little farm.
But she had no real job.
And so they were either
going to go to county relief,
or they could go
to Crystal City.
And so, of course, they
decided to go to Crystal City.
This is Sumi Utsushigawa.
And this is her in the middle.
And she lived up here on
First Street in San Francisco.
Her father Tom and her
mother Nobu were, of course,
Japanese immigrants
to this country.
At that time, Japanese were
not allowed to become citizens
under the 1925 Immigration Act.
And so Tom settled
in Little Tokyo.
And he became the most
successful photographer
in San Francisco.
And in those days, a camera was
a little bit like an iPhone.
And they were contraband
for Japanese people.
They were not allowed
to have cellphones
because the government had an
idea that, for instance-- maybe
some of you knew this--
that some of the crops that
were growing in the
San Joaquin Valley
were pointed as arrows
to military bases.
And they didn't want people
taking photographs of this
to send to the Japanese.
Now, there were no indication
that that was the case.
But that was the day when
fear and scapegoating--
I guess that never goes
away, fear and scapegoating--
came to be.
And so Tom was taken.
I wanted to tell you a
little bit about the camp.
The camp was secret
because according
to the Geneva Convention, if
you build an internment camp,
it shouldn't be any more than
one group, like only Japanese.
Well, from the
beginning, this one
was going to be multiple
nationalities of Germans,
Italians, and Japanese.
And because Roosevelt was trying
to create a pool of people
to exchange in prisoner
exchange, what you're
trying to constantly do is
trade a low-value target
for yourself.
So we're trading
those low-value people
into Germany, Japan, and Italy.
And in return, we're hoping to
get a high-value target, which
Roosevelt had already said
that that was POW's, prisoners
of war, and anyone that
was an American businessman
or a missionary or
an American teacher
that he was going to
try to get them out.
So when ordered to do that,
under the terms of the Good
Neighbor Policy
of Latin America,
he convinced 12
Latin-American countries
to take the properties
of Germans, Italians,
and Japanese.
And then those people were
put onto American ships.
And they were taken to
the Port of New Orleans.
This is about 2,000 Germans,
about 1,050 Japanese,
and about 500 Italians.
They were taken to the
Port of New Orleans, where
they were arrested
as illegal aliens
and sent to Crystal City.
I interviewed more
than 70 children
who were alive and lived and
were children in the Crystal
City camp, including
several of these people that
were from Latin America.
For instance, Carmen
Mochizuki lived in Peru.
Her father was working at
a sake factory in Peru.
And this whole thing happened.
They arrived in New Orleans.
And she remembers that they
were sprayed with things
to make sure they weren't
carrying any disease.
And then they were
put on the train
to be taken to
Crystal City, Texas.
And she thought--
her mother said,
I think we will be killed there.
And that's her first
memory of her whole life.
And they weren't killed there.
But they were traded into
Japan at the end of the war
as part of the prisoner
exchange program.
This is Earl Harrison.
He was the head of the INS.
He was the one who
found the location.
What they were looking
for was something
far from a military
installation,
far from the East
and West Coasts,
and someplace that not
everybody knew about.
Crystal City, Texas is 35
miles from the Mexican border.
It is a tiny little town.
And when Earl
Harrison got there,
there was tumbleweed rolling.
The main street was a dirt road.
But there was a migrant workers
camp there that had 198 acres.
And the migrants were
Mexican migrants.
And they weren't there.
And so in his diary, he
said that Crystal City was
as close to Siberia
as we have in America
and therefore, a perfect place
for the Crystal City camp.
190 acres.
This is Joseph O'Rourke, who
was the commandant of the camp.
He was a border patrol agent
from Buffalo, New York.
And as an aside, he was kind
of down and out at that point.
He was a Catholic
guy from Buffalo.
And his wife was perhaps
a little too Catholic.
And they had split up.
And he had a bit of
a drinking problem.
And so he came to Crystal City.
And it actually
turned his life around
because he became very close
to the children in the camp.
As I said, this is an
overview of the camp.
You can see how it is.
It had six guard towers.
And the guards or border patrol
agents are Texas Rangers.
And they had their guns
trained on the people
in the camp at all times.
The penalty for escape
from the camp was death.
In the whole history of the
camp, which opened in 1942
and did not close until
1948, three whole years
after the war was over-- in
the entire history of the camp,
there was never an
attempt at escape.
It had six guard towers.
And this is the barbed wire.
I mean, most internment
camps or concentration camps
look the same.
They have guard towers
and barbed wire fences.
And Texas Rangers patrol
the area outside the fence.
This is O'Rourke on his horse
patrolling inside the fence.
There's nothing black
or white about my book
because the odd thing about it
is that as internment camps go,
this was a humane
internment camp.
Nobody went hungry
in Crystal City.
There was plenty of food because
everybody worked in the camp.
They all grew their own food.
And the kids that are now
in their 80's and 90's were
so grateful to be reunited
with their families,
even behind barbed wire.
This is a picture of some
Japanese kids playing
on the Japanese side of camp.
But the thing was,
like other camps,
there was a dossier on
every person, which was good
because when I got the records
from the National Archives,
everybody was accounted
for week by week,
day by day, so I was able to
bring them alive in the book.
But every morning they had
to get out for family camp.
So they had a count.
So they had people that came
and counted them to make
sure they were still there.
Each family got 500 square feet.
And so if you had a
family of one child,
you probably did
fine in that camp.
But if you had seven children,
they had to sleep outside.
All of the incoming
mail was censored.
And no one was allowed in
the camp except the guards.
So their relationship
to the outside world
was completely nonexistent.
Having said that, there were
three schools in the camp.
This is Sumi, my main
Japanese-American girl.
And she went to what was
called the American School.
And that was taught by
Texas certified teachers.
And there was also
a German school
taught by German internees,
and an Italian school.
And there was a school
taught only in Spanish
for all the people
from Latin America.
That's Sumi.
They had a Girl Scouts
in their schools.
And there they are.
Everybody was divided.
There was very
little interaction
between the Germans
and the Japanese.
And especially, they
did not get along.
There was a lot of problems in
the camps between the Germans
and the Japanese.
These are German barbers.
They were paid for their work
in what was called camp tokens.
They were little, small tokens.
And they redeemed these
at the general store
for various items.
They made their own mattresses.
They made their own clothes.
And this is Japanese camp
women who were making something
with sewing.
The kids that I interviewed said
that the worst thing about it
was how hot it was-- 125
degrees in the summer--
and also that the place was
crawling with rattlesnakes
and scorpions.
And so there were deaths
from rattle snakes,
including children.
And there were other
kinds of deaths, too.
Some of the people
from Latin America
did bring whooping cough
and those kind of things.
And that kind of deal
spread through the camp.
Anyway, but the Japanese, what
they really hated was they
didn't like American food.
And so they asked
O'Rourke-- he had
a spokesman for the Japanese,
a spokesman for the German.
And the Japanese spokesman
went to O'Rourke and said,
well, we just can't
stand this American food
of beef and chicken.
We would like to
build a tofu factory.
And so after that,
O'Rourke went and learned
about how to make--
with the Japanese,
he learned what was needed.
We're a long way from any
ocean in Crystal City.
And one of the things that
is needed to make tofu
is sea water.
And so they finally
figured it out.
And they used a victory hut.
And they built the first tofu
of factory in Texas, for sure.
And the Japanese were
very, very happy.
And the wives brought their
tofu every day to their kitchens
and cooked.
And when the Germans found
out, they were furious
that the Japanese got the
tofu, and said, we want beer.
And so they built a small
beer hall in the camp.
And this is the beer hall.
And this was a place that
O'Rourke, the commandant,
frequented very often.
Supposedly, there was a
rule that you could only
brew beer once a week.
But this was an often
violated rule in the camp.
Because it was so hot,
they had to create
a giant-- it functioned
as a reservoir
to water the citrus
yards and everything.
And then, because it was so hot,
ostensibly allowed the children
to swim in this.
And that's the only thing that
saved the kids in the camp.
All of the kids remembered
the days of swimming.
These are Germans building
the swimming pool.
And this is just Japanese
internees that had gone by
and picked up a Christmas tree.
And just an indication of
what daily life was like.
But by far, the most
mind-boggling aspects-- and I
wanted to get to it
quickly before I stop--
was the fact that Crystal City
was the center of prisoner
exchange.
In order to create
this pool of internees,
they had to gather
increasing numbers of people.
I was not aware that prisoner
exchange has been going on
since the and in
every war we've ever
fought, beginning in the
American war for independence
against the British.
And this has gone
on in every war.
And it always comes out
many, many years afterwards.
And of course, to find out
that we needed six of them
during the war, and
all from Crystal City,
was very shocking to me.
The first one was
in June of 1942,
only six months
after Pearl Harbor.
And in that thing, you can
feel pretty good about it
because a lot of the
people we got back
were our diplomats that
were trapped in Japan
and a lot of missionaries that
were there and businessmen.
And in return, they got
a lot of these kids,
these Japanese kids, and their
parents from Crystal City.
And two more large
exchanges from Crystal City
came in February and December.
In '43, there were still more.
But I wanted to focus on the
very last exchange of the war
because it shows how
all of these kids that
were the American-born kids who
were traded for other Americans
were collateral damage in
the war, in military terms.
And they were just at the
wrong place at the wrong time.
But as everybody in this room
knows, things often go awry.
And they went awry
on January 2nd, 1945.
I focus on this.
This is Ingrid Eiserloh.
You saw her in the other thing.
She and her family were
part of the last exchange.
On January the 2nd, 1945,
her family left Crystal City.
They took the train to New
York with about 2,000 others.
And they got to the
New York Harbor.
And they were boarded
onto a Swiss steamship
called the Gripsholm.
All of the prisoner
exchanges, the ships
were neutral nations so that if
it had been an American ship,
it would have been blown up.
So they took a
23-day sea journey
across to the port of
Marseille in France.
And once they got out of
that situation in there,
they were under
French supervision.
So then after that,
they took a train
into a little city
called Kreuzlingen,
which is on the Swiss side.
And just across is
the German border.
And none of the kids
that were exchanged
knew they were being exchanged
until I was able to give them
the documents that showed that
they were part of the prisoner
exchanges because
they were kids,
and they did not know why they
were sent to these countries.
But what the documents from
the State Department show
is that Kreuzlingen
was the exchange point.
And when the kids from Crystal
City and their families
got out, another train
came in from Germany.
So it was supposed to be German
people in the United States
being exchanged for Americans.
But at this point
in the war, there
weren't very many
Americans left in Germany.
Roosevelt had done
practically nothing
to help save the Jews in
the concentration camps.
But at this stage,
the State Department
said that they
would take Jews from
Bergen-Belsen concentration
camp who were exchange Jews
and free some of them.
So as a result, although
Ingrid did not know it,
she, an American,
who was supposed
to be a German-- I know
this is complicated--
was traded for a German Jew who
was supposed to be an American.
Once Ingrid's parents stepped
into Germany-- at this point,
Germany was on its heels-- they
had to walk or catch the train,
when they could catch the train,
180 kilometers to Idstein,
Germany, which is where
her grandparents lived.
While they were all
almost to Idstein
and they were on a
train from Frankfurt,
eight P-38 Americans fliers
above fired on that train.
The Germans, who had machine
guns at the front of the train,
at the end of the train, they
killed two of the pilots.
And her mother, Johanna,
who had worked so hard
to try to become an
American herself,
gathered her
children up and said,
the irony of American
flyboys shooting
at my American children.
And so everything got
very, very screwed up.
Sumi, she was sent to Sendai.
And then this is her coming
back at the end of the war.
This woman right here,
this was a photograph
of some of the Jews.
I'm sorry it's blurry,
but it's very old.
After these few
Jews got out-- there
were really only 100 Jews that
got out from Bergen-Belsen.
We weren't taking Jews
into this country.
And so they were taken
to a displaced persons
camp in Algeria, Phillipeville.
This was the girl,
Irene Hasenberg,
who was traded for Ingrid.
I'll show you a better picture.
And these other children
were from Bergen-Belsen who
were on that during the trade.
This is Irene today.
And this is Jacob,
who also was there.
When I went to visit Irene,
she was a big surprise to me.
She was a PhD in global health.
And her husband is in
neuroscience at Ann Arbor.
And she was so stunned
that when I showed her
the papers for
Berlin, which showed
her being traded for Ingrid.
And she said, are you telling me
that President Roosevelt traded
an American girl
for a Jewish girl.
And I said, yes, I am.
And she said, I can
hardly believe it.
And she was 30 years stateless.
After the Phillipeville,
she did manage
to get a sponsor in New York.
And she has led an
incredible life.
And almost all of the
children from Crystal City who
were traded made it back
to the United States.
Once the United States
occupied their villages
in Japan and in
Germany, they began
working for the US government.
And they kept their
families alive.
Ingrid had a very
difficult-- this is
Ingrid at the end of her life.
She died on Pearl
Harbor Day in 2015.
And so she had a
very difficult life.
She never graduated
from high school.
And she had a very different
life than Irene did.
I just wanted to say that over
the course of this research,
began to wonder why
did some people thrive,
like Irene, the Jewish
girl from Amsterdam,
and why did other people
like Ingrid not thrive.
And Sumi was also
one that thrived.
And over the years
of talking to them,
I was really inspired by all
of the American-born children
in Crystal City, who
shockingly never gave up
on their country, which
had, in fact, betrayed them.
I was very inspired by the
Japanese idea of the word
"gamon," G-A-M-O-N, which
means finding some kind
of a practice, whether
it's Buddhist meditation
or calligraphy or Judo or Kendo
to help them stay in the moment
in the face of
unendurable suffering.
I was inspired
by-- I saw children
who tried to honor their father
and mother at the same time
that their father and mother had
been cast out by their country.
I will have to say,
the American officials
at Crystal City,
Harrison and O'Rourke,
did try to save our national
honor by treating the internees
as humanely as possible.
But in the end, it
was Irene Hasenberg,
that German-Jewish
girl that was freed
in the '45 trade
for Ingrid, that
provided seminal
lessons for me about how
to deal with so-called
enemies in a humane way.
I asked Irene where she
had gotten the stamina
to go on living.
Her father John, who had
been a banker in Amsterdam,
had really struggled to stay
alive and get his family out
of Bergen-Belsen.
They became exchange Jews
because before the Nazis took
over Amsterdam,
he had gotten them
false passports from Ecuador.
And so those false passports
were their way out.
But on the train,
the second night
after leaving Bergen-Belsen,
he was so weak
that he died in Irene's
arms on the train.
Before he died, he
told Irene, he said,
I'm not going to make it.
But I want you to promise
that you will do everything
in your power to stay
alive because life
itself is the reason to go on.
And we do not want to give
the Nazis the privilege
of killing one more Jew.
She has led that good life.
And I remember when
I interviewed her,
I asked her how she had
forgiven her enemies.
And here's what she said.
"Enemies are people whose
stories you haven't yet heard
and whose faces you
haven't yet seen."
My gratitude goes to the
characters in my book
that after 75 years
of holding silence
had the courage to
tell their stories
and show their faces and
triumph over adversity.
Thank you very
much for your help.
Thank you so much.
Anybody have any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Are you
aware of the camp--
MALE SPEAKER: Hold
on a second please.
AUDIENCE: Are you aware of the
camp that was outside of Reno?
There was one for
Germans and Italians.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: I don't
remember the name of it.
But I did know there
was a camp there.
It was mainly men in that camp.
It was an all-male camp.
And that one.
AUDIENCE: That's the only
one I'd ever known about.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Right.
AUDIENCE: And my mother's
family was from Switzerland.
But they had an Italian name.
And so my great-grandfather
used to say things, like, yeah,
during the war, everybody
was becoming a Swiss Italian
during that time.
But I know here, we have
a lot of Japanese people
who were interned.
And what I don't know
if it's in your book,
but a lot the times they
would sign their property
to Caucasian people, if
that's the word I can use,
white people, whatever.
And they were able to give
it to them after the fact.
So that did happen.
I'd be interested to know
if it's in your book.
But it's a bit odd.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL:
Yeah, it is in the book.
And sometimes, they got the
property back from the people.
And sometimes, the
people took the property.
And so that was it.
And also, right here
in San Francisco,
Joe DiMaggio's father
was a fisherman right
here in San Francisco.
AUDIENCE: My friend's
father knew him.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Right.
And when Joe DiMaggio heard that
his father had been targeted
to be interned and
sent back to Italy,
he contacted the head of
the Yankees and his father
was not arrested.
But he was confined to
this area and was not
allowed to continue
with his fishing trade.
So it tells you the
level of fear and anxiety
that was going on at that time.
AUDIENCE: Does your
book talk about the 442?
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: The 442.
In fact, Sumi, one
of my characters,
married a member of the
442, the all Japanese--
it was called the
all Nisei division.
That is the most decorated
division during World War
II were the Japanese.
AUDIENCE: Because the
Italians were the number one
ethnic group in World War II.
As a matter of fact, the name
GI Joe is not just a doll.
But the Japanese used to call
the soldiers Joe because they
were all named Joe.
It was Giuseppe.
So I don't understand.
I mean this Roosevelt,
I mean, he really
goes down as the worst
president we ever had.
He really was a bad man.
He wasn't good.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL:
Well, I'll tell you--
AUDIENCE: I mean, he took
our gold away if you had it.
You know?
I mean, he takes your gold away.
He puts in a
taxation system that
has only destroyed this nation,
as far as I'm concerned.
MALE SPEAKER: Is
there a question?
AUDIENCE: The question is,
how do you portray him?
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL:
Well, I have to tell you,
I think that most historians
consider his internment
policies the biggest
mistake of his presidency.
And I was very stunned
at how extensive it was.
And I'd like you decide
what you think about it.
My father fought
in World War II.
And I remember that he
was incredibly frightened
of Japanese people.
And so everybody has a different
history on this subject.
But I'm not preaching in this.
I say, this is what happened.
And I think the events
speak for themselves.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
how many people in total
went to the Crystal
City internment?
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And how many
of them were exchanged?
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Yes.
You do?
Oh, how many went?
Oh, I don't have
exactly the number.
But there were 6,000 people in
Crystal City over the course
of the camp's life.
And most of them
were like 501 times.
So I haven't added
up the exact total.
But it's in the book.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: You can't tell us
everything, right? [LAUGHS]
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: No, no.
It's in the book.
I just don't
remember the number.
AUDIENCE: I'm just joking.
I apologize.
I haven't read your book yet.
It's an amazing lecture.
My question is,
in your research,
have you found any criteria
of who was traded and why?
Was there a list?
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Yes.
Well, first of all, the
criteria was the first thing
you had to do-- Roosevelt
gave J. Edgar Hoover the power
to create a list, a black
list, in 1939, long before we
were even in the war.
But he knew war was coming.
And so that's why he was able
to get these 12 different Latin
American countries signed on.
And so essentially,
what he was trying to do
was find low-value people.
So American children are low
value in the prisoner exchange.
You don't have to trade
American soldiers.
They're high value.
I mean, this is an
astonishing fact.
And Latin Americans, who
aren't even citizens of ours,
who don't know
anything, are even lower
than American children.
So he set out a criteria of
who we wanted to get back
from these Axis nations.
And then, what we did
was we tried to do that.
And there were a few really
bad guys in Crystal City.
For instance, Fritz Kuhn, who
was the head of the American
Nazi Party, was a
prisoner with his family
in Crystal City, Texas.
Germany wanted him back
because he had apparently
gotten a lot of
money that he had
been funneling before the
war effort into Germany.
So Germany wanted him back.
Roosevelt said, hell, no.
And he did not send Kuhn back
until after we had won the war.
So it was all that
kind of calculation.
And during all this period--
this is not in my book--
but that was also when
Roosevelt purchased
Guantanamo Bay, which he
purchased for a military place.
AUDIENCE: It was then?
I thought it was way before.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: No,
during the war years.
AUDIENCE: I thought we had
Guantanamo before that.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: I don't
remember the exact date,
but I think it was
during all of this
when he was negotiating
the so-called Good Neighbor
Program.
AUDIENCE: Well,
in your book, does
it talk about anybody
who was an American that
sided with the Japanese military
because I know that that
happened because
I'm from San Jose
and there was a lot
of Japanese people.
And they've told
me stories about--
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: No, well,
I didn't get into that other
than to say-- I did get into
the fact that by the time
the fathers, who had been
in these all-male camps,
got reunited with their wives
in Crystal City, whatever
loyalty they had to the
US was by-and-large gone.
And so there was a lot
of terrible discussions
between the firstborn
sons of Japanese
and the firstborn
sons of Germans.
And by this time-- I don't
know about the Italians--
because American-born
sons were stating,
this was their country.
Right?
And yet their fathers had
made this decision to go back.
And they didn't want to go back.
So there was a lot of
terrible family discussion
about that there.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that people were
trapped in the Axis countries.
Can you define that a
little bit, what you
mean by "trapped"?
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL:
Well, "trapped"
might have been
a Roosevelt term.
By trapped, that they
weren't allowed to leave once
war began.
And the truth is,
however, many missionaries
didn't want to leave.
And so they hesitated too late.
In the run-up to the war from
the point of view of Germany
and Japan, I don't think even
the Japanese knew what was
in store for them beforehand.
So there wasn't enough
time to get out.
But in Germany, people
knew that war was coming.
And some of them
just didn't leave.
And once war did come, they
wouldn't let them leave.
And so that's what I
meant by "trapped."
AUDIENCE: A 10-second question.
Can you tell us a little bit
about the importance of having
access to archival documents.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I know it's
easy in the United States.
But what about some of the
other places like Salzburg?
History has not yet been
properly researched.
And access is not
as easy as here.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: I can
just say that, for me, it
took me forever-- I petitioned
Berlin for the names of people
that were traded, and Japan.
And I finally got
the list from Berlin.
But Japan won't give
anything at all about it.
And it's a completely
closed thing.
And it's ridiculous
for me now that to have
any document that's in the
National Archives about the war
not out because
it's past 75 years.
Right?
And yet, it is still hard to
get information from the State
Department out.
And there's some information
about the prisoner exchange
program I can't get at all.
And so what I did get,
the only reason I got it
is that it was in
the Crystal City
file, which was
not in the State--
the list of people leaving.
That's the reason,
when I first looked
at these-- why were they--
all the kids would say to me.
And then we went to Japan.
And then we went to Germany.
Why did you go to
Germany and Japan?
I don't know.
If you're 12 years
old, you don't know.
You don't know.
And they were just stunned that
they had been actually traded
for somebody else.
Ingrid, when I told her,
I was worried about how
Ingrid would feel about Irene.
I had never discussed the
issue of Jews with Ingrid.
And this is a kind
of a personal thing.
But when I got
there to her house--
she lived in Honolulu
with her daughter--
I showed her the list
from Berlin, which said,
Irene Hasenberg.
And then I showed her the same
place for the United States,
which said Ingrid Eiserloh.
And that these were
the matched pair.
And she looked at me.
And you know, she
had felt very badly.
She had been a strong
father's daughter.
She'd wanted to please
her father at any length.
And that had not worked
out well for her.
And she looked.
And first, she said,
are you telling me
that I was traded
for a German Jew?
And I said, yep.
And then she said,
well, then everything
that happened to our
family during the war
is worth it because how
many German-Americans
can say that they had any hand
at all in helping a German Jew?
And she was incredibly moved.
And she died three weeks later.
So it was a very, very-- it was
a very sad and also emotional
thing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
I look forward to
reading your book.
My question is about how you
want about doing the research
and how perhaps, other
people like myself, could.
My great-grandfather was
actually an immigrant
from Japan and was
interned in Crystal City.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL:
What was his name?
AUDIENCE: Kaso-ochi Okizaki.
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Well,
I might have information
about him I could look and see.
What was his occupation?
AUDIENCE: He was a farmer.
And I believe the
reason he was interned
is he was one of the leaders
with the JSCL before the war.
So I think my cousin
has, actually,
through the Freedom of
Information Act actually gotten
some files.
But my great-aunt
and two of my uncles
who were Americans citizens
did join him in Crystal City.
I was wondering were there
files on the kids as well?
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL: Yes,
once you entered the camp,
there are dossiers in the camp.
And those files are now open
at the National Archives
in Washington, in the building
on Independence Avenue.
And you can find-- each person
had a dossier at all times.
For instance, I was so
freaked out about it
since my book has to be true.
Time, they couldn't
tell you when did
they arrive in Crystal City.
When did they leave?
Things like that.
And those dates are all
on that dossier of it.
In fact, Ensi Eiserloh
was only a little girl.
And she was run over by a truck.
But she had gotten in
between the wheels.
And that was noted in her file.
So that's in my book.
There were two Japanese-Peruvian
girls who drowned at the pool.
The whole medical file
was in the archives.
So yes, you can find it out.
It's interesting.
One of the things
I didn't make clear
is that the men who were
at Crystal City, who
were charged as enemy
aliens-- they weren't charged.
They were taken because
of their occupation.
And if they were a
leader-- for instance,
if they were a leader of
even an agricultural co-op,
they were taken.
But certainly, for any
kind of political leaning
in the Japanese,
they were taken.
I mean, Roosevelt saw
red after Pearl Harbor,
much more than Bush did after
9/11 because Roosevelt had
been the Secretary of the Navy.
And the Japanese had taken the
whole Navy out, practically,
at Pearl Harbor.
He was one mad hen.
And so, he would
have been, if he
was a leader in the community--
there were 250 Buddhist priests
in Crystal City.
That's a lot of
Buddhist priests.
Every Buddhist priest
that was on the West Coast
was there, and in Honolulu.
And so it wasn't a
[? loyalty task. ?]
It was where you were
in space and time
and who your affiliation was.
And in so many
ways, the Japanese
held onto their culture.
But in so many ways, German
culture in the United States--
you couldn't listen
to Beethoven.
You couldn't speak German,
even in Cleveland, Ohio.
That was considered bad.
And the Germans and
the Italians have never
received an apology from
the government or any money.
And at this point,
the kids that were
in the camp that were
German-Americans,
they wanted an apology
for their parents.
But none of them have ever
asked for money for reparations.
But I sent my book
to President Obama
and asked for an apology
for these children
in Crystal City, who
were completely innocent.
And so far, no answer.
But we give
apologies to anybody.
I don't know why we couldn't--
and we've apologized to Japan
about a million jillion times.
And I think we should
apologize to these kids that
were in Crystal City.
MALE SPEAKER: And with that--
JAN JARBOE RUSSELL:
Thank you very much.
OK.
Thank you for bringing me.
I just love this place, Google.